I want to talk about this album
chemistry except has been listening to
it I listened to it last night and my
daughter is such a massive fan of yours
and she's 19. so I said they gave me
this sneak listen to Kelly Clarkson's
new album and so she got in the car with
me and we drove around listen to the
whole album and she both of us blown
away but my daughter just going on and
on about your range and the way you put
a song across and I think this is your
10th this is your tenth album my tent
someone told me that yeah that's amazing
and I what someone told me that yeah I'm
gonna be honest dude I told I'm
delightful I am delightful not by anyone
here I hire a guy
um but it what's amazing to me is I I
don't I know I think I I feel like I
know great singing when I hear it and I
remember watching your audition tape
which is out there it's fascinating to
see her audition for American Idol yeah
and it's fascinating to know which one
you saw which what do you mean because
they they show you know they edit and
they show you I think they ended up
releasing but they had me actually sing
another song I came in singing at last
yeah that's the one I saw yeah but then
they actually ended up releasing at some
point because people they found out
because they asked me like oh that's how
you sound a slow song can you sing like
an Up Tempo and like literally every
person was singing itchy Gitchy yeah
yeah whatever the the pink the Lady
Marmalade
every soul in the building was
rehearsing that song to sing so I was
like anything but that song I was like
so I ended up singing Madonna express
yourself for some odd reason because
that's not like a but it clearly went
well it went fine but like I just it's
funny because how they edit the show
like nobody even saw that for you well
what's great is watching their reactions
because it's you know you have the the
judges there and it's Paula Abdul and
yeah and they're just they're you starts
they're like okay go ahead and yeah you
come in and you really do look like
you've just come in from selling some
Red Bull to people in a park I literally
probably and then you start to sing at
last and you just cut to them and it's
really fun to see because it's I don't
know it's it's like people seeing a UFO
they're just all looking at you their
reactions are so Priceless they're
seeing awesome Talent
so come out of you which is really cool
well so Randy and Paula were like that
with me but I had to win over the Brit
like he he didn't even remember me he
like I like I came back and he literally
said and like I think I was seeing
respect and it was on one of the lives
or something and and he I was like oh
you can't hear that enough
um he was like I don't even remember you
and I was like thank you that is so
great well it's funny his job was kind
of to be that way and and it's nice
because he also changed my hair color
though so I think he just honestly did
not recognize me or remember me at all
was not impressed by my voice at first
and and I think
I think I wanted to have like this crazy
operatic voice telling you I I but I
literally I got off stage and I was like
well you can't hear that enough like it
was like I don't remember you I was like
okay
yeah I'd rather suck and be memorable
than UNM but not memorable
well he wears sweaters with no t-shirt
underneath no he's like such a fan now
he's so nice oh now he's come around
the show I want him over on the show but
I I think it took a minute yeah this uh
album that you've done chemistry is
about really personal stuff in your life
yeah which is where a lot of great music
comes from tragedy historically but uh
must be I know you wrote some of these
songs maybe a year and a half ago two
and a half to three I I literally had to
sit on it because my my label loved the
the work but I was like I can't
I can't sit and do this I'm not ready
like you know I'm saying to talk about
it like so I and now I just needed to
wait until
um you know we were through it and and
then I could do it but so it's weird to
listen to now because do you feel like
it's all because you went through this
traumatic you know separation divorce is
that
it is and obviously I'm not a songwriter
or anything about it but is that at all
therapeutic to write about it it's only
therapeutic that's the 100 the reason
why I I did it like I wrote so many
songs and I think um you know we all
process things differently and for me
like even when I was a kid I had a funny
enough I had a problem communicating and
really good at it now but um but I had a
problem with it and my mom like shoved a
like a journal in front of me was like
why don't you write and so I started
writing poetry and I and I noticed that
I that's how I would process my feelings
or what I was feeling or I just didn't
know sometimes because there's so many
it just feels chaotic sometimes I'm here
so
um so then it turned into music and so a
lot of that was just me doing it
selfishly but um then you realize like
a lot of people unfortunately will
relate to I mean statistically but
ton of us relate to a divorce rate so um
you know and just loss in general grief
in general so
um I picked the ones that I felt weren't
so
um literal and and okay because we have
children so I've picked the ones that
were okay that I felt like and then um I
put those out but no but the ones that
are super literal those are for me
and they're probably just super specific
and so super duper specific right on
August 5th
a lot of anger I think a couple of the
angry songs made it but they weren't the
ones that were like you know no code red
over yeah go go somewhere else yeah well
it it it's uh it's fascinating to me
because what I know is
um trying to make people laugh and
what's always been
an amazing realization for me at the
times when I've been really upset about
something maybe show didn't go well or
something didn't go my way and I'll
start being talking about it and doing
like a comedic riff about it and then
I'll notice the people around me are
like laughing really hard and you've
been around this because you've been
with me a long time Sona yeah that
sometimes when I'm just venting about
something that went wrong and I keep
venting about it and people are laughing
I feel like wait a minute I just took
this negative experience and I wasn't
even trying to but somehow it just
turned into a way of everybody's
laughing now so some good came out of it
absolutely and I imagine it's somewhat
similar to I mean very different but
somewhat some of the damn same idea I
think it's exact and it's and and I
think it's
um
you know I mean I've said this before
but like especially like divorce in
general is hard separation grief loss
all of that is hard
um I think the worst part though is when
you feel alone like I don't even hang
out with anybody that's really like my
main group of friends like aren't
married don't have children aren't in
the public eye like none of the things
that tick the boxes that I am so which
is awesome that's why we make a fun
group but but at the same time when
you're going through something so
horrendous and so publicly there's
there's no way to like describe that
like there's I just saw your shirt I'm
sorry that's amazing
um I caught my eye that's amazing
um
thank you it's a Conan shirt and uh
they're very sexy it's amazing
um I'm so ADHD like squirrel sorry um
but I think I think when you're when
you're when you're that when you that
isolated and I think everybody relate
covid right people are so isolated like
I think that's the worst to not feel
like you can connect with with another
being and like
heal in that sense and I think that that
that's why we all do crave like maybe
it's not marriage or maybe it's not what
every society tells you but we do crave
companionship and and because you need
you need to connect and you need to it's
almost a process of healing I think for
me dude what do you do you have an
instrument that you use a musical
instrument when you when you were trying
to work something out do you use a
guitar use a piano horrible guitarist
and I like literally I played one tour
and then I found out like halfway
through they were like not putting it in
there
I found out they were like not putting
it in the mix and they were like well we
just know you know you're learning so
like and I was like oh my God I killed
that solo yeah no one Heard It Rock it
on low tonight I was like I fell to it
and I was like okay I'm gonna let the
professionals do it so I Know chords
like enough to like write if I need to
on a guitar piano but honestly most
things
um especially this record
um most of it was acapella just lyrics
and Melody flowing out of me and then we
were worked a track around it and
sometimes I call like I I literally sent
out like a like a code red like any any
artist friends that I knew that were
producers or writers I was like please
send me anything you have that's like
even if it's a random guitar riff idea
or just anything that because I I was
needing to get all of this out and I
just needed different moods and
different like perspectives musically so
um so I wrote like that too but it's the
lyrics in melody or me I love that you
worked with and I I did not see this
coming but one of my all-time all-time
Idols uh is Steve Martin I've just I've
I absolutely adore Steve Martin I
believe he said yes and he had a huge
impact on my comedy and my life and then
I find out that I mean I always knew
he's an amazing amazing uh banjo player
yeah and
um I hear about this collaboration yeah
that you did uh with Steve Martin which
you would have never I what like that
doesn't even matter but it sounds great
yes and the song is so the song is hate
love and and in the song so I wrote sure
um these days it's a really sunny day
um
um no and why I hate love is not that I
hate love it's it's that you hate What
Love Can Do you know and especially so
in the second verse um you know you
watch The Notebook right and you're like
oh that's so beautiful James Garner
crying like all the things you're like I
could this is achievable and then you
see reality in like a movie like it's
complicated with like Meryl Streep Steve
Martin out Baltimore it's one of my
favorite movies and um that's more real
life and so I just thought it was funny
to play off of those I'm very much
inspired by Art like whether it's music
or movies or art or whatever and um so I
I played off that and then the lyric
it's like I'll take Steve Martin over
Gosling like I basically like throwing
Ryan Gosling I love Ryan Gosling but I I
was making I dated him for a while is it
good for you no it's really okay yeah I
know it's not
underwhelming lover
so no so anyway
I have friends I've seen
that I I would choose Steve Martin um
over goslingen and um I literally looked
at Jesse Shack and my producer I was
like do you think because I know he's a
badass musician I was like do you think
in some world he would agree to play on
this because it's kind of a Pop Punk
song and yeah and banjo I thought would
be cool on it and so and it is and it is
and so anyway he said yes
I know and I didn't get to go to the
studio with him I'm so I still never met
him Jesse got to I was working it's so
funny you brought up the notebook and I
just have to relate that I sh uh Ryan
Reynolds was on the show do you remember
this Ryan Reynold was on the show Once
burned into my memory okay so yeah Ryan
Reynolds is on our show and he had this
ID said let's recreate this scene from
The Notebook
so I'm wearing the blue dress
in the rain yeah
they're yelling at each other and
they're yelling each other in the rain
you came back for me yeah and um Ryan
Reynolds is doing Ryan Gosling and that
it culminates with the two of us and was
shot in this like beautiful filmic style
to exactly match the movie oh my gosh
and I am you're Rachel McAdam I'm Rachel
McAdams and my hair is just matted down
and I'm wearing the same dress how was
your ugly cry oh it was fantastic it was
really ugly and um but but it ends with
uh Ryan Reynolds and I had just agreed
that we were gonna Rush each other and
start making out so we do we start
making out and we're making out for what
it felt like four hours yeah but it was
maybe just like a minute you can see it
on the internet but Ryan giving it the
old college no no I just go for it and
Ryan Reynolds at one point has this
mover he's reaching over and he's doing
he's kind of twiddling my ear yeah and
so we just both of those moves yeah
exactly so so um I learned a lot about
him uh and myself yeah exactly and so we
done cut we got it and I'm just like all
right what's next and I move on and
um my wife had watched the whole thing
happen
she saw it on TV that night she watched
it and she said yeah that ruined both of
you for me
I no longer like
I'm no longer I don't like you I don't
like I'm attracted to bugs yeah I now
find you both horrific yeah
but uh I think that's amazing well it's
a good experience it's amazing how long
it lasted oh yeah you know just just go
for it you know when you know that's
coming do you use a mint do you put a
mint in your mouth or I actually just to
get them had a burrito
I had a very garlic a rare garlic
burrito all garlic yeah because what did
I care yeah do you guys still talk at
all
um do you still kiss let's just say we
text a lot